look at this sold out can you believe
this stuff so they were supposed to
deliver it in october
this is going to be an update on the
kettlebell shortage of 2020. i just want
my shoe give me my shoe please then i
was supposed to be november
no
then december
give me my playstation am i wrong for
wanting this bro
i mean
everything just sucks lately take my
money take my money i don't want it give
me my shoe every time i check my email
it's stuck on this right here i don't
even know what that means tonight one
word sums up the feeling along every
line of the supply chain frustration
well the shortages and delays in the
global supply chain threaten a total
paralysis
when the pandemic hit
businesses anticipated that the coveted
recession was coming they thought that
demand was going to drop
but something funny happened
the opposite of what all of these
businesses and economists predicted
happened demand exploded people bought
things like crazy and now supply chains
are choking on that record demand
everyone has had the experience of not
being able to get something
and everyone has had the experience of
paying more for something
prior to the pandemic most of us just
took it for granted that we could get
things ever faster e-commerce made it
seem like everything was right at our
doorstep
but that obscures what was a 14 000 mile
journey halfway around the world it took
months
and when you add up all the automation
all the algorithms all of the hundreds
of people who had to touch those goods
or transport them in some way it's in
total one of the most complicated
endeavors that human beings ever engage
in and yet it happens millions of times
per day
and we take it for granted because all
of that has been rolled behind this
ultimate convenience of just one click
e-commerce shopping
but the pandemic showed us just how
unsustainable and unrealistic that
expectation is
[Music]
so consumer electronics like usb
chargers
they feel like they are readily
available to us right we can get it the
same day
usb chargers are an interesting product
they're relatively simple
the key thing is those chargers don't
sell for a lot so you have to keep your
labor costs down and you have to really
focus on efficiency
the invention of the shipping container
and ocean going shipping
made it cheap enough to move
manufacturing
wherever labor costs were lowest
global supply chains have really brought
us a cornucopia of products
that we might not otherwise be able to
have as much variety as
or as attractive costs that we see
when you buy a product off of the store
shelf or online
that's actually the tail end of a
journey that might have begun a year ago
in a factory that might be half a world
away
[Music]
vietnam has been attractive because of
relatively low-cost labor
if we take the example of a simple usb
charger
it's assembled in a factory in vietnam
and then usually it's placed on a
shipping container that travels on a
barge to an ocean-facing port
there it's loaded onto a ship for a trip
across the pacific ocean
[Music]
the trip across the pacific ocean can
take anywhere from 20 to 30 days
[Music]
working on a ship can be like
living in an office that you can't ever
leave it's high stakes and it's often
mundane and boring
[Music]
because sailors tend to be confined to
these ships and it's almost impossible
for outsiders to get on or off of them
this is a part of the supply chain that
remains invisible to most of us
a watch local is done visually and also
by radar
fortunately some of these sailors like
to record their experiences
the watch officer is in charge of the
navigation and overall status of the
ship
safe navigation of the ship is the
highest priority
the fog is so thick in this area
we can't really see around us so we have
to use a radar
each one of these container ships can
carry up to 10 000 containers
but they can have a crew as few as 20.
so it puts enormous pressure on each
sailor to do their job because if
anything goes wrong the results are
going to be catastrophic for supply
chains
the last thing we want is containers
falling into the sea if we ever run into
bad weather
we keep watch on the overall conditions
of the ship checking the mooring lines
and looking out for suspicious
activities like stowaways or pirates
sea conditions like this can last for
days the relentless pounding the never
ending pitch and roll
i can only describe it as living under a
24 7 airplane turbulence
the biggest container ships are as big
as a skyscraper laid on its side and one
reason they've gotten so big
is that when you look at all the costs
crew fuel etc the bigger your ship
the more money you can make on every
container the cheaper it is ultimately
to ship these goods
but the
bigger you make these ships and the more
efficient you make these supply chains
the worse things go when there's a
bottleneck at one of these single points
of failure the 400 meter long ever given
got stuck on tuesday morning running
aground in high winds reportedly after a
power failure on board more than a dozen
ships are waiting to pass through the
suez canal that's one of the world's
busiest trade routes and each day of
backlog more than 9 billion worth of
goods is stuck and that translates to
about 400 million dollars an hour
more and more shipping containers have
been flowing toward us from asia and of
course we're not really shipping stuff
back
[Music]
[Music]
now we see a large number of ships in
san pedro bay
eventually that cargo is going to land
eventually it's going to hit the beaches
[Music]
as ports get bigger as more and more
flows through the biggest ports they
become single points of failure in a
global supply chain that used to be more
robust
the port of los angeles and neighboring
port long beach represent 40
of our u.s imports and nearly 30 percent
of america's exports showing just how
critical this gateway is to the american
economy
[Music]
we have more than 15 000 international
longshore and warehouse union members
that work on the docks
my job as a longshore worker is to help
in the operations that
move cargo through the terminals on
long beach and los angeles ports
what i typically do is drive a utr that
stands for utility tractor rig it's just
kind of a compact truck that's strong
enough to haul the tonnage so what i do
is i take cargo from point a to point b
to a designated spot out in the yard to
be stacked for outside truckers to come
pick up to take to the retailer's
destination
we've been averaging 900 000 container
units for 14 consecutive months that
used to be one really good month in our
peak season
we use
these giant ship to shore cranes to
unload containers
typically it takes three to five days
but with all of the
problems we're having right now
productivity is suffering
big time
it's taking up to two weeks to
process a ship that would typically take
three to five days
once a container is on the dock a mix of
humans robots and software
is going to be picking it up and moving
it to stacks of containers inside the
port itself where it's going to be
sorted and re-sorted so that it's
available for trucks or rail that are
going to move it out of the port
there is no room
we've gone even higher in the piles for
our ground cranes to have to dig through
and we've also used every
square inch available on our ports in
order to put containers
and it's very very hard to move them in
a timely manner
ports are in some ways amazingly
democratic places which means that
they're often very contentious places
you have the longshoremen that's an
extremely strong union you have the
terminal operators you have the city of
los angeles or long beach who actually
owns the port you have the ships coming
in and finally you have the drivers who
are picking up shipping containers from
the port if you want to make a change
like maybe you operate the port 24 hours
a day because you're trying to eliminate
a backlog nobody owns that entire system
and can just dictate that that happens
there has to be consensus and consensus
with these groups of people is very
difficult
congested ports and higher shipping
costs have threatened to derail our
nation's economic recovery after weeks
of negotiation the port of los angeles
announced today
that it's going to be begin operating 24
hours a day seven days a week
it does no good
to keep a terminal open
24 hours a day
in the hopes that truckers will come
pick up a load at 3am because if they do
they have to bring it somewhere
so not only do you have to get a trucker
who's willing to come at 3 a.m
he or she has to bring it to the
distribution center and that
distribution center has to be willing to
accept the load in the in the dead of
night
we're going to try everything we're
increasing our gait hours number of days
that we worked we're going to be working
overnight we're required but we're also
asking others to step up too and trying
to find new ways to move cargo out
we can't be a one-man show when it comes
to 24 7 operations we're depending on
the terminal operators to order the work
and the rest of the supply chain to also
open 24 7.
[Music]
when we get full on the docks
that means everyone else is not
functioning properly either and
we really can't do anything about it
until the other aspects of the supply
chain start functioning properly
when there's congestion in a port like
this it just reverberates and the
congestion gets worse and worse the more
that shipping times slip the
fewer ships there are to take empty
containers back to asia so the entire
system is like a traffic jam
you know what starts as one person
gawking at an accident pretty soon turns
into standstill traffic for two hours
for thousands of cars
most goods like our usb charger when
they leave the port are taken a short
distance by truck to the inland empire
region where they're processed in a
warehouse before they're distributed to
the rest of the country
[Music]
after our usb charger is unloaded from a
shipping container the next leg of its
journey is by long-haul truck
that's okay right there
am i getting lucky and get loaded early
i'm probably going to be here about an
hour i hope it possibly could be three
we'll just see
how busy they are today and and what's
the uh what their schedule is like how
fast they are
i'm not rolling so i'm not making money
so
that's part of the problem is
when you sit around and wait all this
time the wheels aren't turning you're
not not making any money
i am a professional truck driver
all told over 30 years
i've been driving the truck there are 19
pallets did you want me to floor loaded
you want me to double stack you're not
going to pick up another load right no
how heavy is it i'm an over-the-road
driver i'm gone typically two weeks at a
time
roughly 3 500 to 4 000 miles a week
hauling all types of freight
everything from from housewares
to rice to water to beer
to
name it you put it in that truck in a
holiday
the major strain on the long-haul
trucking industry is that there aren't
enough drivers willing to do the job in
america
now the american trucking association
has projected that by 2028 america is
going to be short 160 000 truckers
you're talking about an 800 billion a
year industry it moves 70 of the freight
in the united states by value according
to the department of transportation
and without it we'd have paralysis you
wouldn't get the things that you're
accustomed to on store shelves nor would
you get them delivered to your door
i began studying the industry 15 years
ago
i was looking at the labor process and
the work that truck drivers do and what
had happened to it since deregulation of
the industry in 1980.
the current driver shortage has been
talked about by the industry since at
least 2005.
the issue with the truck driver shortage
is not one of a lack of people who have
been interested in this job have gone
through the trouble of getting trained
for this job it's really a shortage of
people willing to do that job long term
and that that's you know fundamentally a
retention problem
not not a driver shortage
well here we are a nice backup appears
to be a wreck up here
[Music]
this could be a long time
trucking used to be one of the very best
blue collar jobs in the united states
the the industry was almost fully
unionized by the teamsters union
unionized truck drivers were making up
to 20 more than even unionized steel
workers or auto workers
it was one of the best jobs you could
get and when you
got one of those good jobs you were
likely to stay in it until you until you
retired
and what happened was the industry was
deregulated
1980 the union was pushed out of the big
segments of the of the industry and and
wages and working conditions followed
[Music]
trump driving his blue collar job
there's nothing glamorous about it
you know most the common person thinks
oh anybody can drive a truck
they don't take in consideration you're
gone from your family
you work long hours
i typically work a 14-hour day
my space structure
is everything is based off of a per mile
basis
you have to manage
your available time to drive
to be able to make that and still take
your 10-hour break
how long are you gonna wait to get
loaded
how long does it take you to get loaded
your clock is running and you're losing
time that you can drive
[Music]
what the big limitation is for those
drivers is that they they can only drive
so many hours per day there are federal
rules they have to record the hours that
they drive and that they work now it's
done electronically this clock has got a
lot to do with
when you can make your appointments
you run out of time you legally can't
drive
[Music]
if you get caught you'll get shut down
the typical long-haul truck at a big
company
will only be actually rolling on the
highway generating revenue seven to
eight hours a day
another
seven
hours or so of that day they'll be
waiting they'll be performing other
kinds of unpaid work and then for 10
hours they're required to take a break
you're not paying the driver for the
vast majority of that time you're really
only paying them for the time that they
drive
new drivers might end up getting paid
somewhere in the low 30s
in cents per mile
what that means in terms of total income
is that a new driver might earn
somewhere around 40 to 45 000 today and
in many cases does not work out to
minimum wage better paid drivers in that
long haul segment can can work their way
up uh to sixty thousand dollars or so
an experienced driver for better
companies can easily make more than a
hundred thousand dollars a year
[Music]
there are about three and a half million
truckers in america there are 10 million
people in the united states who have the
kind of commercial driver's license that
would enable them to drive a truck so
that's a measure of the number of people
who've already turned through this
industry
[Music]
so one of the peculiar things about
trucks and trucking in america is that
where every other part of the supply
chain has consolidated and the big have
gotten bigger trucking is still
incredibly fragmented
so
small trucking companies which of course
is the majority of the freight that's
moved in the u.s
they have a limited amount of leverage
right they are
selling their services on a market where
the freight brokers and the shippers
have all the advantages in terms of data
in terms of being able to set rates
and so
those small trucking companies it's very
take it or leave it for them in terms of
loads
the name of my company is avalon
national llc
we're based in cassadaga new york we're
up to about 11 trucks right now and
uh struggling like everyone else
the driver turnover
ours is getting higher now because we
lost a few good drivers and we can't
replace the good drivers that we lost
we really had to work at making sure
that our loads were paying well enough
our drivers that were currently on the
road were staying moving staying busy
completing those loads but also taking
into account that you know they are
human and have a family and everything
at home as well
hold on this is the driver hey rocky
it's ashley
you're all set to pick up that load
a little bit later she said just you
know work your magic and try to get over
there when you can they know you're
going to be a little bit late due to
your drop off time
alrighty drive safe
we've had trucks sitting for
not having drivers which
you know is is
a big downfall for us
you know it's uh
something i shouldn't be doing but i
again i should because i i'm short
drivers
so i'll drive the truck myself it's that
critical
i've owned a couple companies and
it's a tough business to be into
there's times i can't even get back to
sleep i wish i could
but i can't i just got too many worries
all the time
to recruit more drivers
we've increased our pay to uh 71 cents a
mile
that's very good pay today 70 cents a
mile
we're trying to get our benefits a
little bit better
[Music]
it's not the great cowboy experience it
used to be
it's
more complicated
the laws the regulations
put you up against the wall to be able
to meet not only your deadline or your
appointment to get your load delivered
but now you're fighting the clock in
order to have a place to stay safely at
night
there's not enough room to park all the
trucks on the road for a 10 hour stretch
of time so if you don't get parked early
you don't get parked
[Music]
or you can be like some of these guys
you just pull over the shoulder road
which is extremely dangerous to do
and i'll come and break down the game
buy up something to watch on tv
i sleep generally about seven hours a
night
so by the time i eat and watch an hour
or so tv i'm
we made a new done about their newness
try new flavors like our cheesy marinara
baked apples
hi
give me a monster biscuit to go
[Music]
i'm probably running as hard or harder
than i've ever ran
in the whole time i've been driving the
truck
i'm 62 years old and i'm trying to last
until i'm 70.
lord willing my health holds up i'll
make that
that eight years
[Music]
so the stakes here are incredibly high
the average truck driver is aging
they're not being replaced
if these dire predictions hold true
within a decade we'd be looking at
something like paralysis for the
trucking industry
this is really important right now
because we're at this transformational
period
we're moving from the big box supply
store to
increasing e-commerce shipments and
e-commerce is way more dependent on
transportation than than the big box
supply chain
the ease of shopping these days online
amazon those kinds of things where you
get on your phone
and you can for christ's sakes literally
buy your groceries
you're going to get it one way or
another how much are you going to pay
for it you know how long do you want to
wait for it
in 2021 people are not real patient for
waiting for what they want because
they're so used to being able to click
click click and have it on their
doorstep tomorrow
but everybody needs to remember that
no matter what you got
it got there via truck
so when our usb charger is on a truck
its next stop is inevitably going to be
some kind of warehouse it's often if
you're talking about e-commerce what's
known as a fulfillment center
[Music]
good morning everyone
yesterday we received in 15
154 units eight asms and six sellers
come on right up left
one
two three
four five six one two three four
as with trucking working a warehouse is
a physically demanding job
and that's one reason that companies
have problems with turnover and
retaining workers
[Music]
you're gonna go to ups
take down with you
you have to be
fast fun and friendly
you gotta have your mind to it and not
get distracted
when you have to lift boxes
all day it gets very like you'll be
going home achy and you'll be like oh
i'm so tired
most days it's tolerable then some days
it's like oh
it's it's draining
everyone knows how to make a box right
show up
so everyone knows it's the bottom of the
box
all of them are brand new all of them
are getting officially onboarded in
anticipation of working either tonight
or tomorrow night people we probably
reached out to
yesterday
so you're literally talking from
recruiting
to onboard being
on the floor in three days now
and if i could go faster i would
the shift to e-commerce means that even
before the pandemic the fulfillment
center industry was struggling to find
the space and workers to keep up
[Music]
the covid related spike with e-commerce
and direct-to-consumer has absolutely
blown up our business in our entire
industry and what's happening is it's a
little bit like a snake eating a deer
that your supply chain is the snake in
the supply chain it says it's got this
big bulge that's going through it as
being processed
we kind of anticipated the the bulge
coming our way
yeah i'm nervous because there's still
more constraints it's not one deer that
the snake is swallowing it's a lot of
deers right
in its simplest form a truck will
deliver product to us
we will count that product
we will verify that product
we will put that product away into a
storage location
and then we'll wait for an order an
order will come
we'll pick that product
we'll package that product and then
tender to the appropriate carry
so you have in and you have out if the
inn is greater than the out there's only
so much space that the warehouse can
manage
[Music]
we've managed space here by leveraging
our optimization tools and leveraging
our technology
we have a goods to person robotics
and we have person to good robotics both
of those we are scaling up here in the
facility
so one of the big advantages about the
new automation is that it's so flexible
with the robots here we are two weeks
before black friday and we're literally
inducting robots
right now to increase capacity divert is
using technology really to drive the
next generation of what we're trying to
do from a distribution standpoint
i'm on the cutting edge of trying to
create technology and enable alternative
networks to amazon
fulfillment's really been defined by
amazon
so
they've opened the doors and the rest of
us are now finding creative ways to
support that
so at amazon there's this thing known as
the promise
the promise is we're going to get you
your goods in two days but of course
amazon has been raising the stakes
throughout its entire life as a
corporation so then the promise became
one day the promise became same day the
promise became three hours
in order to achieve this in a
fast and efficient way it's got to be
automated as much as possible
amazon of course has been a leader in
this kind of automation but now everyone
else is following suit
[Music]
we're a global third party supply chain
provider
[Music]
the indianapolis campus specifically
we have 12 distribution centers roughly
about 4 million square feet of
distribution space
we utilize
robots and technology in our facilities
because we want to be able to get
merchandise quickly to market
so that bombay sorter is critical uh
within the process of what we do
from the time that we brought the bombay
sorter online to now we are moving
merchandise much faster out of that
facility because of that level of
technology
[Music]
another piece of technology that is
critical is the robots
these robots basically allow our
teammates to pick much faster pick safer
and be able to walk less within the
facility
if you look at how we used to pick
manually we were picking about 70 units
per hour
and now with these robots we're picking
140 units an hour
there's a speed component obviously
but we definitely
keep those capped at a certain level
because
it all comes back to safety
you don't want a robot being at a
extremely high rate
which could have eventually caused some
type of safety issue within a facility
it's to coexist with the employee
not to overtake the employee within the
facility
the introduction of technology can
reduce the amount of walking and heavy
lifting workers and warehouses need to
do
but it can also increase the pace and
the repetitiveness of their work
so how the tech is being implemented in
each warehouse matters
management sets the pace of the robots
and that determines the pace which
humans have to work in order to keep up
the uc berkeley report found that the
introduction of technology and the way
it speeds up work can't lead to more
turnover and burnout
turnover at many of amazon's warehouses
has exceeded 100
according to a wall street journal
analysis of federal labor data and
amazon's own site data
well just finished
a nice 12 hour long shift
so i'm going from work uh amazon
warehouse msp1 in shakopee minnesota
home
one of the downsides to working till 6
a.m is the sun coming up
at least when you want to get to sleep
[Music]
i was a store and then a picker
for what two and a half plus years
your stocking inventory you're
picking things out of the inventory
[Music]
when coveted hit i became a learning
trainer so you train people
hey nice open spot
good morning
some of the things that i train people
on are like how to access a robotics
floor safely how to fix individual
pieces of equipment
i've worked at amazon for four years now
when i first started
my feet hurt i would get blisters
blisters suck
after a long work week you will quite
literally feel hung over the day after
like just from the long hours like i
feel kind of hungover right now from all
of the just stress and strain that's put
on your body
so you have to hydrate a ton
you need to get whatever sleep you can
when i started working at amazon in the
first month i lost 10 pounds
so i had to eat a meal before work first
break second break third break and after
work just to keep my current weight
you have to make different adjustments
like that to your life to make sure that
like you can physically make it through
well i'm awake
uh at least today is my last shift
so tomorrow i'll be able to bring your
mail over
love you grandma
one of the positives the golden
handcuffs that a lot of people like that
keeps them there in spite of the
negatives there would be things like
health insurance
and the time off being flexible that was
also very helpful it's still helpful
like nowadays
so like if you have
you know family commitments or you're
trying to go to school like i help my
grandma all the time
[Music]
it's really helpful because you can use
some of that time off to make that work
with your amazon schedule
you'll either mature
in how you handle things to be able to
handle
different situations
more effectively
you know otherwise you're just going to
burn out
these warehouses are located at
strategic points on our nation's highway
system where land is cheap and widely
available and so they tend to cluster
[Music]
so workers there actually have a lot of
leverage or more leverage than they used
to because they can just go to wherever
is offering the highest wage okay so
we're gonna have to re-palletize those
so they can all sit at
a certain point yeah
please
it's
a very competitive things of working in
a warehouse nowadays when you got
different jobs that's offering you 22 an
hour to come work for them
i started off as a picker
to manual picker to a packer and then i
moved to shipping because i always said
i want to learn everything in the
warehouse that's my goal
to challenge myself
it gets very stressful some days you
have your days to where it's a good day
you have your days to where you just be
like i'm trying to walk out it's
different days to different things if
you think of this in terms of how we
live now there's been this grand shift
between going to the store and buying
your own stuff to paying other people to
do it for us so it's this fundamental
transition between how we used to shop
how our consumer culture used to work
and now how we shop online it's not a
trivial change at all
and it's a creator of millions of jobs
in the meantime because somebody has to
do all that work for us
if labor continues to be a challenge
we'll continue to optimize through
automation and robotics
to offset the labor issue but the
reality is is that the cost of
fulfillment will go up because the cost
of labor will go up
[Music]
so the very last leg of the journey of
our usb charger is coming out of a
fulfillment center
then it's going to end up being loaded
onto a truck at what's known as a
delivery station and that truck is what
will carry it to its ultimate
destination you know a business or your
house
[Applause]
so one of the strange things about the
new world that we live in is that when
we order things online
it's the last mile delivery driver who
might be our only point of human contact
with this entire system
we might even know our local ups driver
or our local postal carrier because they
tend to have very consistent routes
doreen likes her stuff inside because
especially if it's going to rain other
carriers sometimes don't leave it in the
same spot and she's like
searching the farm
so i try to be
very consistent every day
i've been with ups for 32 years since
1989.
i've been on this route for about 12
years going on like 13 years now
it's okay here
come here come here ready
i know see
everything's all good now
the primary strain on last mile delivery
is that we want so much of it even
before the pandemic the challenge was
how to hire enough workers to drive all
of those delivery vans
if you could transport yourself back 10
years
and imagine the packages that you
received at home they tended to be
relatively high value goods you might
have
legal paperwork or electronics or some
highly valued item that you know was was
sent to you and most likely you had to
sign for it
e-commerce requires a much cheaper
system
so the folks who actually do last mile
delivery they just like warehouse
workers have to work to a very high
standard they have to work at a very
quick pace so typically at a place like
ups they're training these drivers
to economize every single action
you have folks who have to operate like
industrial athletes because they have to
move so quickly and so efficiently
while also of course navigating the
hazards of america's roads
[Music]
so today we talked about three things we
talked about keep your eyes open all
right two seconds in the front five to
eight seconds in the ring we talked
about pounding one two three top one two
three before you put your vehicle in
motion after that vehicle in front of
you starts to move
so last mile delivery is extremely
physically demanding because people are
having to jump on and off a truck all
day long they have to carry heavy
packages and it's really as in
warehousing the repetitive motion that
can be damaging to people's bodies so of
course people have to be trained to do
this safely
it's not just about lifting safely it's
about lifting safely two or three
hundred times per day
so there's more than 500 methods
to deliver one package i mean everywhere
from
the three points of contact that first
step scanning my area i'm approaching
the stop i'm scanning that area i'm
singling okay i'm going to be parking
here
and i got my handbrake pulling my mirror
i'm planning ahead okay i know that for
this stop i have
five big packages i know they're in the
back okay so i'm going to pull up to
this place put out the hand cart
i don't even like realize it sometimes
it's just i've done it for so many years
that it's just it just
it's like automatic i just know what i
have to do how are you and i know how to
get it done and be efficient
and safe at the same time
working for ups i don't have to pay for
my own vehicle or insurance on this
vehicle my health insurance is
incredible i get paid pretty well we get
paid almost
40 bucks an hour and after eight hours
we get paid time and a half
i know that ups isn't gonna go anywhere
so when i go to retire in another six
years
i'm gonna be okay and so is my family
[Music]
we
can't do the kind of bulk cheap
transportation
of of goods that amazon aspires to for
instance with
the kinds of services that we had
with ups and fedex at the same price ups
drivers for instance you know very well
paid job
good benefits
and so
what's happening in last mile is an
attempt to create
a much cheaper version of ups or fedex
[Music]
so the trend in last mile delivery has
been toward
contract drivers and it's a way to not
just limit liability but also limit how
much any one company has to be
responsible for anybody's working
conditions
[Music]
all right so it's 1 34 p.m and i have a
block schedule from
2 2 5 pm
there's been a fascinating story that's
developed in last mile delivery
it's almost exclusively driven by amazon
almost entirely similar to uber and lyft
which amazon calls amazon flex where
people drive their own personal vehicles
[Music]
i do amazon flex delivery
i also do a lot of psy
side hustle like the gig economy apps
like uber
doordash instacart
i actually i started signing up for the
amazon flex during the the first
lockdown for colvin
i don't think you can do amazon flex
full time because usually you only get
about 30 hours of work
you are responsible for your all your
own expenses you know gas wear and tear
oil change and all that
basically it's like uber but with
packages
usually with amazon flex it start out
like at 18 per hour for a three hour
vlog so
for a three hour block you would get
fifty four dollars
sometime the blocks would surge up to
like 23 dollars per hour or
sometimes 45 dollars per hour during
peak seasons
it can be lucrative if you're willing to
be patient and leverage all the search
peak season is definitely here
so this block was uh three and a half
hours for 150 750 fam
that's the biggest three and a half hour
block pay i ever seen you know that's
like 45 an hour
mostly i get country routes from one
delivery to the next is about six miles
drive
i've been putting a lot of miles on my
car
as far as physical work a lot of time is
light envelopes and just a lot of
driving
it's usually the different route every
day
i think it's inefficient because you
don't really get to learn your route
your or your
delivery area
in order to keep up with its own demand
for last mile delivery amazon had to
create a last mile logistics network
just like ups's or fedex but theirs
consists of subcontracted
local delivery companies that actually
own and operate the amazon brand advance
and so what they've moved to is a
relatively unique
approach which is a kind of franchise
and so now they you know you can buy 40
vans from amazon or lease them as an
entrepreneur you can hire up to 100
drivers and what they call a dsp
delivery service partner
and then amazon
does all of the planning
so they put all the packages together
label them plan the route and then your
drivers of your franchise will take a
van that you own with an amazon logo on
it and drive to the fulfillment center
load it up and then follow the route
that amazon provides on their phone
[Music]
i've been working with amazon flex for
about two years now
i also
used to work with amazon dsp for about
another 10 months
driving the blue band was i think it's a
very physical job sometimes you have
like 200 stops and
300 packages in like a eight hour or ten
hour shift
my most ever stops in one day was like
240 stops it is where it is
do your job make sure you uh
come home in one piece
you have to be on pace uh with the
amazon's expectation of uh
20 stops per hour
so one of the effects of using
subcontractors in order to do your
delivery
is that when drivers are pushed to make
more and more stops per day
if that leads to an accident then the
parent company is shielded from any
legal liability
and i think that'll be the central
question of the next you know decade or
so for amazon if they continue on this
model is you know what responsibility
does amazon have for those workers and
and what they do out on the roads
[Music]
[Music]
amazon has already become the primary
carrier of its own packages
now it's touting that it expects to be
ups and fedex at their own game we
expect it will be one of the largest
pairs in the world by the end of this
year i think will be probably the
largest package delivery carrier in the
us
amazon's delivery network is growing at
a rapid pace
from 2019 to 2020 its share of us
parcels by volume grew from 13 to 21
which at this point makes it bigger than
fedex
last mile delivery work which has been
fairly high quality work until recently
is facing a similar kind of decline that
long-haul trucking experienced after
deregulation so the job's being
de-skilled
workers are paid less and less
over time and it's causing
very high levels of churn with within
subcontractors for four major companies
we are going to need to hire hundreds of
thousands of
of last mile delivery workers to meet
the needs of e-commerce in the in the
next decade or so and we may have a
shortage of those kind of workers in the
future
when i was working for the amazon
delivery company i didn't see any
future or any career advancement you
know
so i i just quit
[Music]
i really like the amazon flex work
because it gives me a lot of freedom to
choose
[Music]
i know there's a blind spot here because
this is my route
and i've been doing it for 12 years
so i know
all the little hidden
things that uh
that i need to be aware of
so the very last leg of our journey is a
human being picking up a box and walking
into our front door
and our entire involvement with the
supply chain up to this point might have
been as minimal as opening a website or
an app clicking buy now and then that
product arrives the very next day
when you think about
ordering a usb charger online and having
it delivered to your door
that's really a remarkable
accomplishment it's not a very expensive
device
and it came a long ways from the factory
that relied on was
inexpensive transportation inexpensive
labor
and efficiency all along the way
we've really
been benefiting from a very
benign global trade environment
for the last 25 or 30 years
and what the pandemic has shown us is
that maybe that's not necessarily a good
assumption
what the pandemic really highlights for
us
is
how vulnerable a lot of those
links are to
disruption
consumers are finding themselves having
to adapt to the frustration of
intermittent shortages not being able to
get what they want because one thing or
another can't get through the supply
chain
beyond shortages obviously one of the
biggest impacts of supply chain issues
are increased prices
it's difficult to predict the
persistence and effects of supply
constraints but it now appears that
factors pushing inflation upward will
linger well into next year challenges in
supply chains
make it difficult to
fight inflation with the usual tools
which is adjusting interest rates the
most powerful financial institution in
the world is telling us that interest
rates aren't necessarily enough to deal
with all of this inflation
as a result of these supply chain
challenges companies are rethinking
where things are manufactured and how
far they have to travel in order to get
to us
one of the questions that a lot of
people have asked because of the
pandemic is
about all this manufacturing that has
moved offshore and can we move it back
onshore
that was really driven by the labor cost
differential which was substantial so
moving from a high cost country to a
low-cost country
economically that's pretty
straightforward
moving
from a low-cost country reshoring to a
high cost country
that's a whole different question we'll
see some but we shouldn't underestimate
the challenge
it's a big day for the tech industry in
texas samsung officially announcing it's
bringing a 17 billion dollar
semiconductor factory to taylor
companies like samsung have pledged tens
of billions of dollars to build
factories for manufacturing microchips
within the united states
intel specifically has pledged 20
billion dollars to build a facility in
ohio
this is a major win for ohio
and it's really a game changer a game
changer for our economic future
it shows just how big of a problem these
supply chain issues are
and just how different the present is
from any point in the immediate past
i think what we saw during the pandemic
was an inability to rapidly shift to
meet changing patterns in demand
the question we have to ask is
is it likely to happen again
[Music]
[Music]
you